it is time to talk some college football
now in depth and one of our favorites
over the years including this one that
is coming to conclusion tonight happy
new year Bruce Feldman how are you Bruce
I'm okay what you take out of the
weekend's events and the college
football playoffs Bruce its kind of how
we thought it was Alabama and Clemson
are just better than everybody else in
college football they were recruited at
a higher level
they look physically different across
the board than the other teams and
that's what you know it showed out for
all the people who who were skeptical a
Notre Dame they got way more way more
proof or evidence for them to be
skeptical down the road but I know
that's a good thing for college football
of the Irish and it certainly you know I
think it must be a lot of question marks
about what's the best thing for college
football going forward because we're
talking about expanding and yet it just
seems like right now you know don't
think the BCS era would work better or
it's just pick the two best teams but I
don't know it's a very interesting time
in the sport right now well I mean Bruce
you brought it up so I'll just walk
through the door cuz I mentioned it
earlier in the program I think that this
weekend actually pounds the table even
better makes my case for eight teams
getting in because Georgia and Ohio
State when you are looking at the
landscape this year did not deserve
spots based on the metrics that we
measure the Final Four with in 2018 did
not deserve spots over Notre Dame and
Oklahoma based on the resumes but when
you open it up to eight teams Georgia
and Ohio State certainly get in and why
couldn't they win first round games and
then meet up with Alabama and Clemson in
semi finals and give us better games I
think that this shows you that it is
absolutely necessary that we need eight
teams in Bruce well I think it's
necessary because at least it drops the
charade of there's access for everybody
who's in FBS football and have a chance
to make the playoff that's not true now
if you had any
he'd play up and there was an at-large
spot for a group of five you know there
would be that underdog makes it get
blown out 42 14 but I think that part is
positive one thing that I kind of dawned
on me you know this weekend just i sat
at the Oklahoma you know Alabama game
28-nothing and just thinking about it is
when you go to four teams what it really
did is I think it helps Alabama and
Clemson because those schools they may
make a sputter and maybe something will
just the planets align wrong with a nice
tumble once but so it gives them a
little margin for error where they might
have not have had it from the other way
and I think at this point now it's just
like you know it just feels like a
foregone conclusion you know that old
Behrman line that's why they played the
game it feels like you know sometimes
it's it it's not playing out that way
it's just just kind of what you thought
it was it is and you know I'm still
proven otherwise
I think that's just the reality to
college football right now I'm to the
gap in the haves and have a lot this is
so why so what is the first blush
sentiment on an eighteen format right
now as we're sitting here on the last
day of 2018
Bruce you know I think what Jim Delany
the big Big Ten Commissioner speaking
out publicly as he did to the athletic
last week I think that was a big step in
the direction of Nagin's and change I
think eventually it's going to get that
way they have to sort out a lot of a lot
of the you know structure of it what it
would do the length of the season you
know you're not getting rid of
conference championship games because
quite honestly for the for the SEC map
SEC it makes so much money and that is
going to be a big bargaining chip when
their deal comes up and they're not too
distant future so they got you know the
power brokers of the sport got to figure
out some stuff about logistics on it but
I think it's I think it's inevitable to
be honest Bruce Potter when Bruce
Feldman of Fox Sports and national
college football insider for the
athletic here on the Rich Eisen show
okay Bruce so handicap what the national
championship game is going to look like
a week from tonight yeah I was impressed
with Trevor Lawrence
the freshman quarterback for Clemson
they got good receivers Reb Travis
deacons a really good running back
ultimately I think Alabama's going to
win this game because hedig Alabama is
just too good up front with Quinton
Williams against Clemens offensive line
which I don't think is going to hold up
well enough I mean I think it'll be more
compelling and more of an even match of
them sort of what we saw Saturday
because Clemson loaded up front and I
think they'll give Alabama more problems
than anybody else they've faced just
because they're D lines on a different
level
LSU doesn't have those kinds of guys
right now Palmer has a few of them not
enough and I miss asipi state has has
probably the closest version of that but
I just think Alabama's so good on all
levels and what we saw the other night
is cooiie I talked to one of their
coaches two days for the game and I said
with 85 80 percent is that worried that
he goes tell you I feel like even a
hundred percent you watching move around
that's what he looked like
and those Alabama receivers are really
good running backs we good it's a
complete offensive scheme in a way that
Nick Saban really hadn't had as great as
they been they had got a complete off of
defeat they got one now
what was Dexter Lawrence gonna be able
to play you think for Clemson that would
be a big addition he has you know he's
been set for peds right now what do you
think he won't be able to play but
that's just a hunch cuz usually it's
hard to overturn those things but
that'll be one of the storylines to keep
an eye on as we get closer you know to
Friday and really just everybody get me
here into into the bear all right now
let's let's move let's go in a wider
scope with you in a few minutes we have
left you with you Bruce Feldman what in
the heck happened with Mark Richt
in Miami and Manny Diaz who is you tell
me is it was it true that he was
interviewing for the offensive
coordinator position for his new job at
Temple when he got a call from Miami to
come back to campus as the HC is that
true
well let me give you some of this
particular so what happened with more it
occurs you know they really struggle
this year on the field especially on
offense and there was pressure on Mark
Richt to make a change and move on from
his quarterback truth well as
quarterback coach is John Rick his son
that's what I was told really was
driving behind him stepping down as
recently as a couple of weeks ago one of
Rick's assistance was being pursued by
another power five job and it was
tempted to leave and Rick said no
suffice it's all going to be good here
so that's what changed was the you did
not want to make some hard decisions on
the offensive staff and that led to him
saying I'm I'm walking I'm stepping down
now with many years the thing of such a
role once I've recorded last night then
he is was still in South Florida I mean
he coached a bowl game he was there
still it still there one like he
returned back to campus it is still in
South Florida but you were actually
interviewed yesterday an offensive
coordinator job candidate for his staff
at temple and that's what his phone was
starting to blow up hey you know this is
a situation we like if we like you to
take this thing over with him I think
it's worth really noting here he was the
best thing that Mark had going on this
originally they were really good on
defense man he's in Miami got really
smart guy he's been in the brain behind
the turnover change two years ago they
kind of took off and gave them an
identity they had had in a while and
everything I was told by the leadership
around inside of Miami was they really
liked the only man he was a great fit at
Miami because the cleared really
responded to him they're hoping now that
that he can bring kind of that same
compliment to the offensive side of the
ball where's the dragon and we'll see I
mean I thought tell you what and this
was something that happened I reported
you know it was gonna happen class he
was he was the target and within an hour
they got that so credit to because he
didn't want to let Temple drag on with
this in the middle of it well I mean we
rarely talked temple football nationally
let alone on this show Bruce but another
guy that temple is identifying at the
time before hiring Manny Diaz was Don
Brown the defensive coordinator at
Michigan Michigan getting blown out by
Florida after getting blown out by Ohio
State that said NFL teams are said to be
as we are speaking in hot pursuit to use
a phrase of the day here on the Rich
Eisen show of Jim Harbaugh is it
possible that Michigan loses their head
coach and defensive coordinator in the
next several days
Bruce I mean it's possible I could see
Don Brown being the guy at temple if
your temple you got a lot of good
coaches come and go in the last few
years when Don Brown older I don't he's
been a head coach for he's really
well-respected
he's from the Northeast you know Don
brown goes there and does well he's not
going to be leaving for some bigger job
three years from now I think if you're a
temple I think that should be appealing
at this point I know it's a tricky thing
when you're hiring somebody on their 16
as far as the Michigan thing I think you
know I had this conversation a couple
weeks ago yeah I just don't see how Jim
Harbaugh walks away from Michigan and me
that would be quitting be can I say it
this way because anybody quitting just
because the main job if you're him job
number one is Beach or hated archrival
and nobody hates that school more than
him and to walk away the way it would
end it that's job and I just don't see
him moving on to the NFL for everything
I I know of Jim Harbaugh that just seems
like out of character no I and I would I
would agree with you Bruce but even I
and I say this with all you know honesty
even I would understand it if Chris
Johnson and Woody Johnson call him up
and say here's a 13 14 million dollar a
year check how in the heck do you say no
to something like that in this day and
age but Richie's making a million
dollars a year in a much cheaper place
to live and again ties my castles and
meet it talk about somebody else money
goes a long way I don't know what what
what the added six million dollars a
year okay we change your quality of life
I just again I just um
you're the ultimate competitive you're
not the ultimate financial guy you're
the ultimate competitive football guy
you're the Michigan guy how do you walk
away after it was the way Ohio State
Michigan s played out how do you walk
away from that I just the money to me
just doesn't add up in regardless of
that would be over that would entice
them so much if you would just pull the
plug on alright so then give me the
college coach do you think that the NFL
is going to go and grab or as the best
opportunity to grab or you think is most
likely to be grabbed over the next week
or so Bruce I'm really about pursuing
that rule from Baylor because briefly
for the Giants on the line coach there
he impresses everybody who comes in
contact with him he's done a really good
job rebuilding Baylor after it was in
complete shambles after the horrific
scandal there if they sit down and get
him for an interview I think it would be
hard for people to say no to him I don't
know if he's ready to just walk away
from Waco but he interviewed somewhere
last year and impress people I think
he's only he's only gonna get that much
better
I don't Matt Campbell's manual here I
don't think Matt Campbell is gonna leave
Iowa State we'll see him out Lincoln
Riley I don't think it Riley would have
left there and then the one wild card in
this hat fits whose game is tonight for
Northwestern I haven't heard a long time
ago the only job you would ever consider
leaving northwestern for was to be to
come to the fairs but he does have
sometimes the Packers could be ad who
hire them as now you know up there so I
I don't know I I don't think this would
take the Packers I just I just think he
knows he's got such a perfect situation
quorum but it is the Green Bay Packers I
don't know Dan it's Aaron Rodgers and
Marc Murphy who is the president of the
team is was the athletic director who
did hire him to Northwestern so he's not
only up there he's the guy who's gonna
be essentially deciding who's the next
coach in Green Bay that would be a may
be remarkable I don't know if that's a
fit who knows but they would probably
know better than us it's just been a
crazy weekend man it really it really
really has and last one for you
Urban Meyer's game here at the Rose Bowl
on
Tuesday do you believe this is for sure
on planet Earth his last game as a head
coach is college football the last game
of the head coach for the Ohio State
Buckeyes after that I'm not sure I think
a lot can change in two years I think
Bob Stoops is done coaching I don't know
if I I'd be lying if I said I don't
think anybody knows for sure I don't
think he knows Bruce happy New Year to
you
oh yeah well down the road later this
week man we're gonna call you up we got
we got we got a big game coming up on
Monday enjoy that one Bruce Bruce Alvin
Fox Sports in the athletic here in the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience